Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain a comedy drama film
called “Secret Zoo.” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
Kang Tae-Soo works a dead-end temp position at a
renowned law firm JH. Tae-Soo dreams of one day
landing a permanent position at the firm but so
far he has been unsuccessful. Tae-Soo’s law firm
has been hit with scandals after scandals.
Currently, its vice president Min Chul Hyun
is in prison for stock manipulation and
embezzlement. A group of protesters have
been camping outside the JH Headquarter for more
than a week to protest against the firm for being
unjust and exploitative. Tae-Soo’s college friend
Song also works at the firm as an associate. The
latter always invites Tae-Soo for drinks on the
weekends but Tae-Soo doesn’t want to face his
friends who are a lot more successful than him.
One day, JH’s CEO Mr. Hwang is mobbed outside
the HQ by the protesters. The protestors hurl
obscenities at Hwang, which aggravates him and
he gets into a fight with the mob. The mob easily
overpowers Hwang and seeing his boss in trouble,
Tae-Soo puts himself in the line of fire to
save him. The CEO takes notes of Tae-Soo being
manhandled by the crowd as he drives away.
Impressed by him, Hwang invites Tae-Soo for
dinner, where he meets Rakwan group’s
Vice President and Hyun’s sister
Min Chae-Ryung. After Ryung leaves, Hwang gets to
know more about Tae-Soo. Hwang promises to give
Tae-Soo a permanent position at JH if he manages
to revitalize a failing zoo called Dongsan Park,
that one of JH’s UK-based clients Gabrield Inc.
has acquired. Tae-Soo couldn’t be more excited
and accepts the deal immediately. However, Hwang
gives him an ultimatum and says that he has
exactly 3 months to revitalize the failing zoo.
In the next scene, Tae-Soo quickly heads over to
the zoo and lo and behold, he learns that the zoo
has no animals except for a troubled Polar bear
and some other animals that no one would pay to
see. Tae-Soo talks to the remaining zoo staff
and they reveal that the zoo’s animals
have been taken away by the loan sharks
that the zoo’s previous owners owed money to.
The zoo staff consists of former director Seo,
Veterinarian Han, Hye-Kyung, and Gun-wook. After
learning that Tae-Soo is the new director of the
zoo, Seo proceeds to leave but Tae-Soo convinces
him to stay, saying his experience will be needed
to bring this zoo back to life. Tae-Soo proposes
buying animals but he is told that one can’t buy
endangered animals. They could seek special
permission for research and breeding from the
government but it could take well over 3 months.
Later that night, while returning back to his
living quarters inside the zoo, Tae-Soo is given
a scare of a lifetime by a stuffed animal which he
mistakes for a real tiger. One of the laid off zoo
staff reveals that he is taking the stuffed toy
to sell it for some money. The next morning,
Tae-Soo relays his problem to Hwang but the
latter tells Tae-Soo to return back if he can’t
make it work. Realizing that he may no longer have
a future at the company if he fails to deliver,
Tae-Soo promises to make it work at any cost.
Tae-Soo then notices pictures of the zoo’s annual
soft toy contest on the wall and suddenly, an
idea strikes him. He proposes the idea of having
the zookeepers dress up as animals. He stresses
that people won’t be able to tell the difference
between a realistic animal costume and an animal
from a certain distance. The zoo staff quickly
get on board in the name of saving the zoo but Han
refuses to partake in the foolishness. However,
Tae-Soo plays with Han’s heartstrings by bringing
up the story of her becoming a vet because of the
zoo’s polar bear Black Nose, eventually persuading
her. Tae-Soo then contracts a Hollywood costume
designer to design a realistic Lion, Gorilla,
Sloth, and polar bear costume. Within two weeks,
they receive the costumes and Seo suggests hiring
actors for the job but Tae-Soo turns down the
suggestion, saying their secret could get out.
Left with no choice, Han, Hye-kyung, Gun-wook and
Seo become the Lion, Sloth, Gorilla and Polar Bear
respectively and the rehearsals begin. Soon,
the zoo’s gates are opened to the public and it
receives groups of kindergarten kids and senior
citizens. The zoo staff initially struggle but
eventually get the hang of their new job, managing
to fool the visitors. Their effort manages to
attract 75 visitors in a week but the numbers are
not enough to keep the zoo open so Tae-Soo insists
on getting a giraffe to lure more visitors.
Meanwhile, Hye-kyung’s boyfriend Sung-min dumps
her after wasting 5-year worth of her savings
on a convenience store near the zoo. Seeing
Hye-kyung crying, Gun-wook storms into the store
wearing the gorilla costume and destroys it.
Sung-min reports the gorilla to the police but
he is brushed aside as a lunatic. The next day,
Sung-min shows up at the zoo, where Gun-wook again
attacks him as a gorilla, exposing their secret
in the process. After learning about Tae-Soo’s
scam, Sung-min threatens to report them to the
police but Hye-kyung convinces him against
it and asks Gun-wook to apologize to him.
Later that night, Tae-Soo visits his costume
designer but to his dismay, he learns that he has
taken off with the deposit, leaving behind only
the head of the giraffe in the warehouse. However,
Tae-Soo refuses to give up and he uses the head
of the giraffe to trick his visitors. Soon, Seo
falls sick from sitting out in the sun in the hot
costume so Tae-Soo takes over his role. He quickly
learns that cosplaying an animal at a zoo isn’t
an easy job as some unruly visitors keep throwing
stuff at him. Tae-Soo also gets tired of sitting
in the sun and when no one’s looking, he grabs
a coca-cola bottle thrown by one of the visitors
inside the pit and drinks it to quench his thirst.
However, some visitors manage to capture
Tae-Soo gulping down the coca cola bottle.
That day, a representative from JH
arrives at the zoo and reveals that
Tae-Soo’s request for animal purchase has been
approved. After giving him a tour of the zoo,
Tae-Soo manages to send the rep off. That night,
Tae-Soo gets a call from Song, who tells him about
his plans to visit the zoo with his kids. After
seeing JH spending so much money and effort to
keep the zoo up and running, Tae-Soo asks Song
about Gabriel and Song reveals that Gabriel is
Hwang’s own shell company that he uses to manage
his slush fund much to Tae-Soo's astonishment.
The next day, a crowd of people show up at the
zoo and Tae-Soo learns that his polar bear has
gone viral after the video of the polar bear
drinking coke hit the internet. Tae-Soo and
his team couldn’t be more excited and thanks to
the polar bear, the zoo becomes a massive hit.
Hundreds of people flock to the zoo everyday to
see the bear drinking coke and over the weekend,
the zoo makes a massive profit of $100,000.
One day, Gun-wook finds Hye-kyung despairing
by herself and talks to her. She is still
reeling from her breakup and Gun-wook offers
to take her out on dinner. Meanwhile, Tae-Soo
notices Black Nose roaming outside in the pit.
He then finds Han watching an old childhood video
of Black Nose by herself. She reveals that she let
Black Nose out of the cage so he could get some
fresh air. The two then talk about Black Nose’s
worsening behavior. She says that no matter how
spacious the zoo is, it is still a cement cage for
the polar bear. She reveals that she once had an
opportunity to send the animal to Canada where it
could live in the wild but she decided to keep it
around, hoping that if she did her best, it would
get better. She laments her decision and thanks
Tae-Soo for saving the zoo before parting ways.
The next day, Hwang offers Tae-Soo a permanent
position at JH. Tae-soo is ecstatic at the news
but his happiness soon turns into disappointment
when Hwang reveals his plans to bulldoze the zoo
and build a resort. Rakwan Group had purchased
over 25 million square feet of land around the zoo
and they also wanted to buy the zoo itself
but Hwang’s shell company Gabriel swooped in
and bought it up. Hwang then ordered Tae-Soo
to revitalize the zoo so Gabriel could sell the
land to Rakwan Group at a much higher price.
Tae-Soo tries to convince Hwang against selling
the zoo but Hwang dismisses him. Dejected,
Tae-Soo returns to the zoo to deliver the
bad news but he is surprised by Han and others
with a success party. Former employees of the
zoo also join the party and thank Tae-Soo
for giving them their livelihood back.
Seeing them so happy, Tae-Soo can’t bring himself
to break the bad news. However, a former employee
of the zoo from earlier in the movie arrives and
reveals Rakwan’s plans to build a resort on top of
the zoo. Tae-Soo confirms the news and the former
employees leave disappointed. Han and others feel
cheated by Tae-Soo and refuse to hear him out.
Left with no choice, Tae-Soo returns to his new
job in Seoul and gets on with his life. However,
he still regrets what’s happening to the zoo.
When the Rakwan group’s team arrives to demolish
the zoo, Seo gets into an altercation with the
company staff and injures himself in the process.
The zoo staff reunite in the hospital and Han
proposes a solution. She suggests opening
the zoo and putting Rakwan on blast publicly
for trying to demolish it. The public campaign
works and the media and environmental activists
get all over Rakwon like a bad rash. The
development enrages Rakwan’s vice president Ryung
and Hwang promises to remove the miscreant
employees from the zoo premises. However,
it fails to calm Ryung down as her attempts to
revamp the image of the company have tanked badly.
Hwang promises to resolve the problem as soon
as possible and leaves. Hwang is later visited
by Hye-kyung’s ex-boyfriend Sung-min, who tells
the CEO the truth about the fake zoo animals.
Tae-Soo notices Sung-min leaving Hwang’s office
and figures out that he has ratted them out.
Hwang and his assistant immediately leave for
the zoo and they are closely followed by Tae-Soo.
Before Hwang gets to expose them, Tae-Soo alerts
Han and others about the development. Han stops
Hwang from going into the room where the
polar bear is kept. Shortly afterwards,
Tae-Soo joins them and Hwang warns him to
tell him the truth about the zoo animals
but Tae-Soo continues to feign ignorance.
Enraged, Hwang forces his way into the room
and finds Black Nose sleeping. Mistaking
the bear for a fake one, Hwang challenges
the animal, almost getting himself killed in the
process. To calm Black Nose, Han lets him into the
pit while Hwang proceeds to leave. However,
Hwang returns to check the polar bear again
when he becomes certain that the giraffe is
fake. Hwang gets into the pit with Black Nose
and challenges him again. Black Nose attacks
him and Hwang passes out. To save his boss,
Tae-Soo puts on the polar bear suit and
lures Black Nose away from Hwang. It works
and Hwang is brought back to safety but at
the expense of Tae-Soo who is attacked by
the bear. The angry bear tears Tae-Soo’s
suit open, exposing him. But fortunately,
Tae-Soo manages to run to safety just in time.
After the public debacle, Tae-Soo apologizes
to his team and offers to take all
the blame to protect them. However,
Han and others oppose the idea, saying they
all are as guilty as him. Hye-Kyung wishes
outloud that they could do something about
Black Nose and other remaining animals.
Suddenly, an idea strikes Tae-Soo yet again.
He claims he can save the zoo and goes to meet
Rakwan’s Vice President Ryung. He proposes to run
an ecological park for Ryung’s resort where the
animals could live. This would not only remove the
roadblock stopping the construction of the resort,
but it would also save Rakwan’s image from being
tarnished further. Ryung agrees on the condition
that Tae-Soo gets Gabriel on board. Through his
friend Song, Tae-Soo retrieves hard evidence
of Hwang laundering money using Gabriel. Tae-Soo
then threatens to leak the documents to the press
and police if Hwang doesn’t agree to sell the zoo
to Rakwan. Reluctantly, Hwang agrees to the deal.
Several years pass by and the movie cuts to a
scene of Ryung presenting a video of the Rakwan
eco park consisting of various real wild animals.
Seo and others have been hired by Rakwan Group.
Moreover, Black Nose has immigrated to Canada.
The movie ends with Tae-Soo and Han visiting
Black Nose in his natural habitat.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out. Thank You for watching.